In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for July 10th, on which we commemorate the 45 holy martyrs
of Nicopolis in Armenia.
In about the year 316, during the reign of the Godless Licinius who renewed the persecution
of the whole of the Eastern Empire, the prefect Lucius arrived in Nicopolis in Armenia,
avid to shed the blood of any who resisted the imperial decrees.
Leontios, Maurice and Daniel, the leading men of the city, and 40 other Christians, presented
themselves before him of their own free will, and bravely confessed that they were disciples
of Christ, urging him to carry out his intent.
Licious summoned them to appear before his tribunal, where Leontios declared that
they refused to worship idols in obedience to the commandments of Christ who had been crucified
and had risen for the salvation of all.
Enraged by their boldness, the prefect commanded that their jaws be broken, with blood
blows from stones.
As their companions cursed the magistrates, that servant of Satan, Leontios spoke these
words to them, brothers, do not curse those who earn damnation for themselves, but bless
those who persecute you.
Licious then tried to win them over by promises, but when the saints replied by mocking his
empty words, he had them thrown into prison and forbade their jailers to give them any
food or drink, despite the torrid heat.
They entered the prison glorifying God who had found them worthy to suffer for his name.
And Leontios encouraged them to persevere to the end, reminding them of the glorious deeds
of the martyrs who had gone before them.
A woman called Basila, or Basiana, succeeded in escaping the watchfulness of the guards and
brought them water for their thirst.
The next morning they appeared again before Lissius, who submitted them to terrible tortures.
They had their bodies torched, and then the soldiers scraped their wounds with potchards.
The holy martyrs bravely endured these tortures until the sixth hour, when they were taken
back to prison, and Basila came again to minister to them.
That night a resplendent angel appeared to them, announcing that the end of their struggle
was at hand, and that their names had been written in heaven.
The jailers, Manias, and Birlados, or Birlidados, were witnesses of this vision and rushed
to throw themselves at the feet of the saints, confessing their faith in Christ.
The martyrs embraced these eleven-hour laborers, as brothers, promising that they should not
be deprived of the trophies that they had been promised.
News of the conversion of the guards were transmitted to the governor, who, roaring like a lion,
had the forty-five martyrs brought before him, and commanded his soldiers to cut off their
hands and feet with axes, and then to cast them all into a furnace.
Their remains thrown into the river Likos, were recovered by devout Christians.
They took them to Nicopolis, where they were thence-forth venerated as the city's holy
protectors.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.